[Music]
so
there's a politician
in spain
espana string them up who has a very um
interesting theory about sex
he believes that the main purpose of sex
is about procreation okay
what so why are people doing all this
casual sex [ __ ] okay sounds like a loser
he thinks this shit's whack this guy
gets no puss dude he's never jacked off
before no i guarantee you he jacks up
all the time apparently he gets a lot of
puss so that's not true oh it really
says who the article the article i don't
think this article says that wrote that
he wrote himself he might be trying to
reproduce a lot that's why oh that's a
good one that's a good one he's a
professional we need more people though
we don't across countries we don't need
more people we just need good people
wait
counterpoint
aren't world population uh birth rates
going down i think it's sure they are
first world first world yeah japan right
is a very japan's had the problem for a
while japan and korea europe's [ __ ] up
europe's pretty bad uk is bad yeah our
china is pretty bad too right china's i
don't know chinese people will always be
able to
create do have a couple of friends in
their like mid to late 30s
that have made the commitment as couples
to not have kids anymore which i feel
like
in my parents generation is like unheard
of
they said they're not going to have them
anymore they just never don't want kids
they just don't want it it's like that's
not for us we're just like we just like
this we like this
and you know that's us and that's not
even like kids or no kids that's like
our parents have like 10 11 kids
and now we're like dude one's a lot yeah
well it used to be they had so many
[ __ ] kids because half them were
gonna die that's true and you need your
progeny to live on and [ __ ] have you
guys seen like a [ __ ] bar graph of
how many baby boomers are
are there compared to us so like if you
add millennials and gen z together they
don't even make up the baby boomer
generation
it's like a [ __ ] big tall boner and
two [ __ ] little dicks my whole life
i've been thinking or i've been hearing
about how when the baby boomers
retire how [ __ ] social security is
but the beauty is they'll never get to
retire
hey jokes on them
work till you die they did good they did
good those politicians are sneaky sneaky
[ __ ] these guys so now this cat is
saying that sex is strictly for the
purposes of procreation and that
the mindset of sex is
more casual has led to the depopulation
of spain
due to the degradation of their culture
i see you understand really there's just
banned condoms there in spain then yeah
why why would you do that why
i don't know anymore my now i'm very
insecure about my thought realm i was
[ __ ] up anthony i was really [ __ ] up
man i had no idea where that was going
if you're catholic you already don't
believe in condoms right i think so i
don't know i didn't know that was a
religious thing because you're not
supposed to like spill the seed right so
like if you it probably depends on how
strict of a catholic you are i love
generalizing as much as anybody but i
don't know if that's the case
because if you throw away your condom
with the jizz in it that's spilling the
seed they're supposed to plant the
caesar they're supposed to bust nuts
inside yeah yeah
no
people do [ __ ] say some christian
stuff in bed though yeah like oh god oh
god oh god you know
okay
oh
mary magdalene
[Laughter]
immaculate conception
[Music]
say peter say peter
pope francis oh that get well that's a
different context yeah look at that i
went too far there that's somebody
getting railed in the ass by pope
francis
i'm not an archer boy
i will say uh this could be wrong so
hopefully someone in the comments can
like shed some light on this but i could
do it too cool
hopefully somebody in the comments um
but i remember when i went to go study
abroad in spain and we were randomly
casually talking about things like sex
uh in america like third base is like
oral right like home base is like the
glory hole and sex right but i believe
over there
or places in europe it's like sex is
more casual so it's like third base but
like to like get oral sex oh that's more
like whoa
that's like but i don't know that was
when i was this is like over 10 years
ago that's safe for your partner yeah or
that's maybe either more intimate or
more something but i have no [ __ ]
idea i heard that
home run is is actually love and
relationships yeah first base is
negative orgies what
first base is orgies space is orgies
what baseball are you playing
it goes from physical to emotional i see
so like the first step is you meet each
other and you're in an original and then
you have a 69 yeah and then the second
step is you invite 69 base one it's it's
when you connect this human centipede
69.
yeah okay and then you keep i'm
following you keep going into it and
then um at the end of it you decide if
you want to be in a relationship or not
oh i thought it was gonna be you join a
sex cult or not
oh i thought home run was like you hold
hands finally yeah
that's a very bart home run dude that's
the [ __ ] grand slam for burst one
you're what are you just avoiding hands
the whole time you're like [ __ ]
you're just like no no no elbows only
lick your [ __ ] you can suck my dick but
we ain't holding hands i don't know what
kind of girl you think i am get the [ __ ]
off of me yeah yeah don't touch my hands
pope francis so the population of zamora
has declined by over 30 000 people over
20 years and this guy who's a far-right
politician
he's saying that this is why
we forget that the main purpose of sex
is procreation there are people who free
themselves from the chains of family and
marriage to dedicate their existence to
satisfying only their sexual desires
dude i love that he phrases it as like
the chains of family and children i'm
like yeah you don't sound make it sound
super great bro they don't do that i'm
just like you're making it sound like a
prison sentence yeah uh
no thank you it's like they're cute
chains cute chains no they're not cute
like titanium chains maybe so they don't
they don't like fuzzy like little golden
gold or something like you get them from
like claire's
no
no he um he's being very serious about
this because they're they're actually
really worried about the population
issue
when you think about the way that our
culture is set up like here too if we
did have a population issue that'd be
kind of crazy like when you think about
even the job shortages that we're seeing
we're like you see everywhere it's like
workers wanted and [ __ ] like imagine
there's
it's not just people who are saying like
yo pay me more or whatever it's people
who don't even exist enough yeah it's
even like like sriracha right like we
need to stop production because we don't
have enough workers so stuff that you
even like almost kind of take for
granted was it a worker shortage or was
it a supply shortage i thought they were
not i think it was a workers shoulder i
thought they were running out of chili's
but is it working short because we don't
have enough people or it's because like
none of the people not wanting to work
exactly yeah right but just things that
you feel like would never end or are
taken granted for you know it's just
like anything can stop any time which is
crazy that's very true
yeah i always thought we had too many
people on the planet i still feel that
way depends on i mean globally yeah we
are overpopulated as like humans we're
always talking about like depleting
resources like climate change and not
being able to like you know go back and
i've also read the opposite where if
people like uh were spaced out over the
land we have actually way more land than
we need yeah there's like enough i think
it just i understand that but that's the
same as being like if everybody just
split the money equally we'd all be fine
you know what i mean that's true that's
true which is also true maybe why don't
we do that we should just do that all
right maybe in ryan's can i get some of
your money i think it's worked real well
in russia
for china
right cuba too i forgot cuba it's all in
vietnam it's pretty good oh they're
doing that with like the chinese
celebrities right now where you can only
make so much money yeah
like guarantee they're hiding that
somewhere like there's a loophole how
how could they control that they're like
you made it too much money this year
yeah they just can't base off like
endorsement sponsorships tours or
whatever the freak like that because
like i think too many people were
getting like too much power with the
people yeah but then you just like you
know hide it get get gifts or whatever
yeah but in in the you know land like
that caught sag sucks then yeah
they need to create a screen act the
gale man that's not a like a here's the
minimum you can you can make it's that's
[ __ ] are there unions in china i
don't think
you know the only reason why the us
doesn't have a population problem like
the europe and all that is because we
allow a lot of immigrants in so like our
birth rate all first world nations like
birth rates suck because we become
educated we don't have kids to our 30s
or whatever look at all the major cities
right like we're not popping out [ __ ]
kids no and so to make up for that
deficit we let in more immigrants one of
the one of the things people were
talking about though conspiracy wise
about like
why you know the roe versus wade and all
that they don't want abortion it's like
one is they want more kids to have
higher birth rates but the other thing
is
what about the states that will allow
abortions right so their method is allow
a ton of immigrants in and then because
you know how like what's his name was
gonna do the thing where immigrants get
free healthcare
newsom newsome our our our great
california dear leader that's right
right so like that's my favorite it's
like they're both working the legal
immigrants have to pay for the illegal
immigrants healthcare basically that
makes sense but then it'll bring in more
illegal or just bringing more immigrants
in general if they hear that they're
like well free healthcare but it's like
both states are in cahoots there where
like the right and the left they still
want a huge birth rate so they're going
to use different tactics to do that all
i know is when a popular when a
politician starts talking about sex
stuff that makes me really want to vote
for them that's true especially if it's
no sex i want them involved for fun yeah
yeah no sex were fun you having to put
[ __ ] legislation out like that like
no casual sex or
i think they better get on it
they better start yeah no but real talk
though
i think the reason why is because
[ __ ] money dog like to
like to [ __ ] pay for a family in a
and like everything it's so expensive in
the city most city folks don't have kids
yeah and they don't have like why would
you yeah
and then if you go rural it's easier to
do that and it's more like family
oriented yeah it's like like the public
school systems too right like the reason
why they
call you when you ditch school isn't
really because they care about your
education it's every kid that shows up
that day they get more funding so if
half the schools ditch then they're
losing half the funding because they
don't they only get paid based off of
how many kids show up so i think it's
probably the same thing where it's like
the census where like hey california
we're having a lot more people now can
we get more federal funding
oh yeah you guys got way more than last
year so maybe maybe that funding should
be like split amongst like the state and
like the people who are having children
because if you got paid to have kids
maybe we'd have more kids maybe
it's faster to have a full-grown jorge
come over
yeah than to have to sprout a whorehouse
print more money and just pay people to
make babies i want my horrors imported
yeah that's what i do this is why nobody
wants to listen to dancers talk about
politics ryan's not here shut up and
dance
you